david i like the idea of single payer
but how do you deal with increased
demand
for medical services if single payer
passes if everything is
free at the point of care people are
going to start
going to doctors for all sorts of
procedures how do we deal with that
this is sort of a ruse okay and i like
the
i i love the opportunity to talk about
this because there's so many different
things to consider
first of all let's apply the sniff test
to it
um if you're talking about unnecessary
medical procedures
where people would get them for kicks if
it was free
what actually falls under that umbrella
that has no preventive benefit what what
i mean by that is
in every single payer proposal i've seen
um
unnecessary cosmetic plastic surgery
that's not medically necessary it's not
reconstructive in some way for example
wouldn't be covered by single-payer you
you would still have to say if i want
breast implants if i want a nose job
absence some trauma or you know a
mastectomy or other situations it's not
covered i've got to pay for that out of
pocket okay
so once you take cosmetic plastic
surgery off the table
what what what somebody who people are
going to get
hip replacements just for kicks even
though they don't really need them
people are going to get um you know
dental cleanings which redu dental
cleanings reduce the cost of care by
preventing cavities as an example and
preventing gum
issues so when you really get down to it
you could see a decrease in demand
for some of the more resource intensive
health care
preventive care reduces the number of
er visits for heart attacks and strokes
and abscesses that could have been
treated early on
and reduces uh demand for icu and other
acute services because
you're catching medical issues earlier
you're addressing them
earlier and you prevent some of that
really expensive specialized care so
number one
when you really think about it the
things people are mostly not doing
because of financial obstacles aren't
things
people do for fun and this gets to the
most important point
and really the fundamental reason why a
for-profit health care system doesn't
make sense demand
for most medical services is completely
inelastic
okay let's talk this through and i hope
i can do this clearly going back to my
uh micro economic days if you take a
good
like for example i don't know uh
sharpies as an example where there's
lots of
substitutes for sharpies and
uh sharpies are an item where you might
prefer the sharpie
to a pen but you might not but there's
subs okay etc
if sharpies are a penny each demand
explodes
tons of people if the sharpie goes to a
penny
i'll buy a ton of sharpies and just use
them maybe instead of a pen or some
other marker
if the sharpie goes to a thousand
dollars demand goes to almost
zero very few people like sharpies
enough to pay a grand each and they'll
switch to something else you'll go to a
pencil
you'll go to you know whatever if
there's no obvious alternatives you'll
you'll you'll get uh chalk i don't know
okay so that's there's elasticity there
significant elasticity
when you take if you uh fall down and
you need a hip replacement
whether the hip replacement costs a
million dollars
or a hundred thousand dollars or twenty
five thousand dollars or ten thousand
dollars or a thousand dollars
my demand for a hip replacement is
absolute
if i need a hip replacement um and it's
essentially zero if i don't need a hip
replacement no matter how
cheap you make hip replacements no
matter how much access you give me to
hip replacements with single payer
and of course it ignores that a doctor
wouldn't recommend one if there's no
reason to do it
my demand for a hip replacement is zero
so this is not a normal market good
and so the um reality is
you know consider appendectomy i have i
had an appendectomy a year and a few
months ago
uh up until the day uh on which my uh
appendix
started swelling and requiring to come
out
my demand for appendectomy services was
zero regardless of the cost i wouldn't
even take a free appendectomy i wouldn't
even
take money to get an appendectomy
suddenly i need one
and my demand is absolute okay so this
is the point the the increase
that people are are uh expecting um
is simply not going to be there from the
standpoint of people getting
services they don't need most of the
services people would avail themselves
of
if money were not an object are going to
be preventive services that actually
reduce acute disease in the long run and
reduce costs so
it's essentially a farce that's the
reality
and one last thing i know some people
will say but david when
access to medicaid is increased
emergency room visits go
up very very different medicaid is not
medicare medicaid is primarily
for poor or disabled folks and
in particular it's folks who have a
backlog
of more serious chronic issues than the
average
population and it is not representative
of what would happen
uh bigger picture uh you have there
there's
very many specific issues with that that
make it not analogous to what you would
see bigger picture all right so let me
know if i'm missing anything but that's
my general take on that